foreign
watch so already here in his
prescription he's gonna give me young
energy so I'm gonna internalize the
young energy and then I'm gonna move
that young energy
so very simple but the spiral is already
there the spiral is already moving
around
let's just start
pull two steps like but you want the
turn Okay uh so I move my Center the
sand goes here this hand goes here
the sand is moving from this way starts
to tilt and this hand is accentuating
the tilt you see that tilt in his body
okay so that's what I moved internally
today let's try
okay so uh
on this hand you always want that tilt
so let's just look at the hammer okay
I'm gonna make his uh Center go uh in
down and get that elbow to go this way
and this hand is going to do the same
thing this way it does the same thing
now both hands are tilting both hands
are children
don't just open
so in other words uh
you can't come in I'm controlling when
he comes in I'm actually bringing him in
but all throughout the cycle he can't he
can't push in you feel that Taylor high
he can't push in you can't push in you
can't push in you can't push in you
can't push in and I'm loading him so uh
uh I'm not sure if that's visible he
knows how hard he's pushing do you
understand this this is something
totally totally different okay that's
not what I'm doing I am moving him in
this Handler okay
and this hour you guys see
our spiral and more spiral so you're
going to have your
oh
[Music]
look look how look how this hat is also
bringing him in
it's not just casually opening but at
the same time he can't push on that pad
he can't push on that hand he can't push
on that hand he can't push on that hand
okay boom
that's what I'm working with
[Music]
okay let's try it again
okay so now I'd like you to pay
attention to the back foot
you're doing everything the same here
and you come around don't have this back
foot
do that rudder
now
oh
no
no it grounds
um
Center moves
oh
don't pick up the back foot okay
well he has to come forward too he he
comes forward
so I don't leave him out there and he
hits him
I I haven't come forward okay
so I would like for you to look
on how far his hips past my hips
okay
you're normally a very common way his
hips stay there you see and then I am
yeah I want to bring his hips past you
you see they get way past me do you see
that or no
here
boom
he comes he comes in
I need him to go past
okay
you have to bring him in
you bring him in
and you turn him
you don't keep them out
and push in you bring them in and you
turn him
okay
if if we bring this into tank on you'll
get way more tilt on his body so you'll
get way more tilt on his body
and then
that's the goal the Note 10 upon and
then just do it here
bring
[Music]
it bring it bring him in boom
foreign
[Music]
this one is to get a sense of move I'm
moving in okay
I'm moving him
just get out of the way
okay
you feel that
foreign
okay release good